sur ces lignes de production près de
300000 radiateurs électriques sont
fabriqués chaque année passée la découpe
et la mise en forme les pièces
métalliques passe par la case peinture
avant d'être assemblés
ultime étape la pose d'un film chauffant
élément clé pour obtenir une chaleur
douce via
tout ce système là de câbles électriques
on vient chauffer la partie avant du
radiateur dès l'allumage du radiateur et
donc la chaleur se propage sur tout le
métal de la partie avant du radiateur
c'est là on va ressentir la chaleur
instantanément et c'est une chaleur
douce c'est pas quelque chose
d'intense 21 seulement laventure terme
or c'est celle de deux frères orléanais
en 1931 etienne et germain mort se lance
dans la production de petits appareils
électriques du quotidien avant de surfer
sur le boom de l'électroménager en
parallèle l'entreprise développe
sapinière de radiateurs électriques
certains en forme de grippe en d'autres
de paraboles vous à une résistance
électrique est au centre de la parabole
on voit cette belle cette belle parabole
en cuivre qui du coup tu diffuses la
chaleur cette chaleur douce dans la
pièce à l'époque faudra reconstruire et
surtout au bois au charbon peut-être que
des poêles à pétrole donc avec des
chauffages dangereux des chauffages qui
parfois dégage une odeur puis des
chauffages un peu compliqué alimenté
aussi là vous brancher la prise et le
radiateur chauffe donc c'est le confort
immédiat le progrès technologiques et
les nouvelles attentes des ménages
français ont poussé l'entreprise à
concevoir des modèles plus économes en
énergie des appareils connectés et
pilotable à distance
certains permettent d'alléger eux mêmes
la facture d'électricité
il est équipé de capteurs des capteurs
de présence des capteurs d'absence ce
qui va lui permettre d'adapter son
fonctionnement au rythme de vie du foyer
c'est un appareil également qui est
équipé d'une détection de fenêtres
ouvertes s'il détecte une fenêtre restée
ouverte il va automatiquement baisser la
température pour éviter de chauffer
alors qu'on n'a pas besoin parmi les
dernières innovations du fabricant des
radiateurs toujours plus connecté
capable de donner la météo du jour
ou de jouer la musique de son choix
une
non